Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus
ich hüte die kimonade und du denkst nach
ach ja was bleibt denn so anderes übrig
nichts zu tun hat denkt man auch viel
nach weil ich meine du musst dich ja ins
harte Leben
also deswegen ich habe gehört du hast
eine ziemlich harte Woche ja wirklich
also meine Woche war ein bisschen anders
irgendwie viel passiert ähm ich ich
also das was mir am meisten hängen
geblieben ist in zwei Sachen und die
hängen auch tatsächlich miteinander
zusammen ich hatte Jonas Kratzenberg in
der Sendung denn interessantes Buch
geschrieben hat über seine Zeit als
deutscher Soldat in der Ukraine ist eine
krasse Geschichte ist ein junger Mann
ich glaube 22 ist Jonas und der packt
seine Koffer in Aachen
und stellt sich vor seine Eltern und die
sagen junge wo willst du hin und er sagt
ich fahre jetzt in die Ukraine zum
Kämpfen zum Kämpfen und seine Eltern
haben was gesagt seine Eltern sind
fassungslos ich glaube seine Mutter ist
Ärztin seinen Vater Polizist total
pazifistischer Haushalt werden gesagt
und meinte also nichts ist weiter weg
von denen als Krieg aber er hat dann
auch sehr ehrlich wie ich fand
beschrieben eine gewisse Faszination
fürs militärische und hat dann
beschrieben wir dann einfach in sich in
dieses Auto setzt und losfährt und sich
dann dort meldet in der Ukraine und dann
meldet man sich dann ja genau man man
man man geht hat sich da irgendwie bei
so einer Behörde gemeldet und hat dann
alle möglichen Dokumente mitgebracht hat
oder sowas das heißt wahrscheinlich
anders ja also irgendwie so ein
kriegsrekrutierung durch Büro oder so
genau und da meldest du dich und sagst
ich bin der und der und ich will ja ich
will da nicht sofort erstmal für den
Spion gehalten
nein weil es tatsächlich das habe ich
ihn auch gefragt woher die Leute alle
kommen da hat in einer in einer mit
einer Gruppe gekämpft von von Leuten die
kam wirklich aus der ganzen Welt viele
Israelis Kanadier Australier Amerikaner
vorher schon vernetzt
da haben wir hier so eine Art
fremdenlegionen oder
wie ist das im spanischen internationale
Brigaden ja richtig und ähm dann habe
ich ihn gefragt wie das läuft und er
sagte ja und da schreibt dann einfach
irgendwo und Pass Ausweis genügt und
dann gibt's 500 € versprochen zumindest
die dann aber selten wirklich fließen
weil es offensichtlich ist es beschreibt
auch sehr ehrlich in der ukrainischen
Armee in diesen Struktur nach wie vor
sehr viel Korruption gibt und wenn Du
und wenn du dann sozusagen wirklich zum
Fronteinsatz kommst dann kriegst Du noch
mal 3000 oben drauf und auch die haben
aber dann viele von denen nicht wirklich
gesehen
sind Belarussen viele die da dabei sind
für die das sehr sehr viel Geld ist die
einfach Geld und Geld verdienen da
hingehen ja
dann gibt es also wirklich Menschen von
überall her Aserbaidschan es gibt auch
Russen Russen die teils in der Ukraine
Leben teils aber auch aus Russland
rübergekommen sind um jetzt in der
Ukraine an der Seite der Ukraine zu
kämpfen es gibt also sozusagen auch die
die anderen Russen die sehr wohl
erkennen was da gerade passiert und was
das für einen für einen ungerechter
grauenvoller Krieg ist und was für eine
miese Nummer und die dann zum Teil auch
so so Partisanen Dinge dann machen
was ja vielleicht mitgekriegt ne geht
einfach dann rein in die in die Dörfer
und hat man sich dann
extrem schlecht begrenzen offensichtlich
ja genau genau der hat mir berichtet die
haben dann haben dann diese Gruppe
zurückgeschlagen zwei von denen sind
gestorben
wurden verletzt und die dies geschafft
haben diese Partisanen haben dann von
den von den Russen so ein Schützenpanzer
geklaut und sind mit dem wieder zurück
über die Grenze ist der totale Wahnsinn
das klingt so
völlig unrealistisch oder es klingt
unrealistisch aber was mich bewegt hat
tatsächlich ist das klingt jetzt so nach
das sind so ein paar heißblütige Jungs
zu viel Testosteron und und so viel
Videospiele gespielt in der Kindheit und
und jetzt wollen wir es mal in echt
machen so so könnte man das so einfach
abtun aber so ist es nicht sondern der
ist schon eine große Ernsthaftigkeit
dahinter und ich glaube ihm das auch das
gesagt ich bin Soldat ja Berufssoldat
Panzergrenadier und so wie ein Pilot
fliegen will und ein ein Arzt irgendwann
operieren will so wollen wir halt
irgendwann auch unserem Beruf nachgehen
aber das ist neu ja also ich meine ja so
dass etwas der Bundeswehr früher war ja
hoffentlich kommt auch kein Krieg
richtig und und wenn dann sich sofort
ergeben also diese Witze die man über
die Bundeswehr ja früher gemacht hat das
ist ja einfach nur darüber irgendwie
drei Tage Widerstand zu leisten ist die
Amerikaner da sind also dieses diese
Haltung zu sagen
ich habe das gelernt jetzt will ich das
auch mal zeigen was ich kann das hat er
früher überhaupt nicht gegeben ja es ist
ohnehin also wirklich zur Fremdenlegion
genau also wer den Zweiten Weltkrieg
großartig gefunden hat und das Soldaten
tun geschätzt hat vorsichtlich
ausgedrückt der konnte zu Fremdenlegion
gehen und da gab es ja reichhaltige
Einsatzmöglichkeiten in China Algerien
und so genau ja er hat auch sehr sehr
klar darüber reflektiert er sagte ich
habe noch nie so viel Unehrlichkeit
erlebt und Lüge wie in diesem Krieg
und ich ich nehme an das hat aber damit
zu tun dass es in jedem Krieg schlicht
und ergreifend so ist ich erinnere mich
am Flughafen in Chisinau haben wir
Kollegin französische Reporterin im
Flugzeug getroffen die gerade vom von
der Front kamen bachmut und die immer
wieder dorthin aus Ukraine war in den
letzten Jahren und auch jetzt in diesem
Krieg und die auch sagt er bitte auf
allen Seiten gelogen dass ich die Balken
Bienen sich das nicht vorstellen und
Jonas berichtete dann auch also von der
der bei einer der ersten der ein guter
war der das gesehen da kriege ich jetzt
noch Gänsehaut also er die Leichen auf
der Straße sagt und das war es war so
brutal da wurden einfach Menschen auf
dem Weg zum Einkaufen die wurden einfach
einfach Kopfschuss einfach hingerichtet
wenn Sie das Pech hatten gerade so ein
russischen Panzer in die Arme zu fahren
und da wurden systematisch er meinte in
ihr PIN war das etwas anders ja nicht
weit weg aber ein Botschaft war
erkennbar was das Vorgehen war das
Vorgehen war wirklich
Zivilisten greifen maximalen Terror
verbreiten vergewaltigen
Angst auszulösen und den
widerstandsgeistorischen genau das hat
er hat er so berichtet und das ging ihm
erkennbar unter die Haut er hat aber
auch von ukrainischen Kriegsverbrechen
berichtet sagte da gab es eine Situation
und sie fünf russische Kriegsgefangene
sie da irgendwo aus dem Graben
rausgezogen die haben sich dann ergeben
und plötzlich wurden drei von denen
komischerweise drei warum weiß keiner so
genau die wurden einfach rausgezogen und
dann gingen drei ukrainische Soldaten
mit denen in so einem Wald verschwanden
in diesem Wald und plötzlich hört man
drei Schüsse
und dann kommen die ohne die drei Russen
wieder zurück
und alle haben es gesehen alle haben es
mitgekriegt und alle haben verstanden
was da passiert ist und dann erzählt man
sich wenig später naja da werden wir
jetzt eine Untersuchung machen und so
weiter aber er sagt der Glaube daran das
ist da jemals eine ernsthafte
Aufarbeitung dieser Dinge geben wird der
der fehlt einem total ja 100 Jahren wenn
es vielleicht krieg ist genau die zwei
bleiben Leben damit sie das mitkriegen
und ihren Kameraden erzählen können oder
damit Sie wissen was ihnen passiert
könnte sein also auch die abschreckungs
ja die haben berichtete doch darüber
weißt du dass das ist halt das Ding ne
da sind halt alle Gesetze der
Menschlichkeit einfach aufgehoben na
genau das ist Krieg das ist Krieg und
das ist Menschen die wahrscheinlich
nicht drin sind wahnsinnig schwer
vorstellen richtig richtig ja damals
erzählt von dieser Dokumentation weiße
haben über den Tschetschenien Krieg
und ich habe ja Gott sei Dank solche
Dinge nie erlebt aber in diesem in
diesem Dokumentarfilm kam das alles so
nahe diese unglaubliche Verrohung zu der
ganz normale Menschen fähig sind in
Kriegssituationen genau und die Dinge
mit einem machen die man sich bei sich
selbst in seinen schlimmsten Albträumen
nicht vorstellen kann ja ist der Punkt
und das ist jeden Tag ne also das ist
das ereignet sich ja jeden Tag dort ja
es war auch es war auch so ich habe ihn
dann natürlich irgendwann an einem Punkt
es waren wirklich intensives Gespräch
und ich habe mich da einfach so
reinfallen lassen
und ich habe ihn dann irgendwann gefragt
ob er denn selber auch Leute umgebracht
hat und er sagte darüber rede ich nicht
und darüber rede ich noch nicht mal mit
meinem ehemaligen Kameraden aus der
Bundeswehr darüber rede ich nur mit
denen die dabei waren auch übrigens
typisch ganz typisch das war ja nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg so genau ja also wenn
die Männer aus dem Krieg zurück haben
die ihren Frauen nicht erzählt haben was
sie gemacht haben richtig und es gab
auch häufig so dass wenn bestimmte
Gräueltaten begangen worden sind dass
man Gelübde abgegeben hat nicht darüber
zu sprechen außer eben in diesem inneren
Kreis was dich dann noch mal mehr
zusammenschweißen einer der Gründe für
die Beliebtheit von Veteranen treffen
irgendwann
wechselseitig psychotherapeutisch
austauschen zu können über die man nicht
redet glaube ich sofort ja ich glaube
das eigene das Entsetzen sozusagen über
das wozu man selber fähig ist ich glaube
das kommt dann irgendwann und ich denke
dann auch immer dann ist der Weg auch in
die Depression nicht weit und ich frage
mich immer wieder nach wieder einfach
ein normales Leben gelingen soll wenn du
das gesehen hast wenn du diesen wirklich
diese diese diese das ist ja also Gewalt
in einem unvorstellbaren Ausmaß wenn du
dort beschreibt das in Teilen auch wenn
du dann Menschen siehst die einfach
nicht mehr wie Menschen aussehen auch
auch interessant über ganz also wir
haben ja beide öfter schon darüber
gesprochen dass dieser Krieg so gestrich
wirkt ja so ganz konventionell ja aber
tatsächlich hatte eine Dimension über
die nach meinem Dafürhalten dann zu
wenig geredet wird die ist wirklich 21
Jahrhundert das ist ganz ganz modern
Drohnen Drohnen spielen eine ganz ganz
ganz entscheidende Rolle in diesem Krieg
und Jonas funktioniert anders als in
früher das sowieso genau
also früher war das ja so im Zweiten
Weltkrieg ich habe mal den Deutschen
ihre Geschichten erzählt ja also
Niederlagen waren von Begradigungen und
zum Quatsch ne und ähm wenn man was
anderes wissen wollte dann musste man
unter Lebensgefahr in englischen Sender
werden aber sonst waren diese
Informationen nicht verfügbar und jetzt
wird ja von beiden Seiten der
Informationskrieg global geführt richtig
und das ist natürlich auch was völlig
anderes und jeder kann mit seinem Handy
Bilder aufnehmen und und sozialen
Netzwerke Fluten und so das auch neu ja
die Drohnen vor allen Dingen ne was man
immer vergisst also ich wusste das nicht
in China gibt's gerade einen riesigen
Absatz für Drohnen sind sogar Drohnen
die angeblich in der Lage sind Geschenke
irgendwo abzuwerfen
aber natürlich werden die benutzt und
missbraucht um Granaten abzuwerfen und
all diese Drohnen haben Kameras und mit
diesen Drohnen wird sehr genau geguckt
wo sind die gerade wo haben sich die die
Wagner Söldner zum Beispiel wo haben die
sich eingegraben und dann fliegt der
genau darüber und er selbst ist auch von
einer solchen Drohne erwischt worden
schwer verletzt worden hatte Splitter im
Auge hatte dann irgendwann eine schwere
Operation weil er innere Blutungen hat
bis heute ganz viele krachanatsplitter
im Kopf wo die Ärzte sagen besser wenn
wir das nicht anfassen solange Du damit
leben kannst lass es einfach so wie es
ist aber das hat ja alles in seinem
Körper und diese Drohne hat ihn einfach
von oben erwischt und ich sagte wie wie
kann das sein dass das kriegt die doch
mit der meinte nein die Fliegen so hoch
er hat in der ganzen Zeit war ein Jahr
dort hat er eine einzige Drohne immer zu
Gesicht bekommen und dann haben die
versucht mit Kalaschnikows diese Drohne
die direkt über ihn stand ganz ruhig vom
Himmel zu holen sagte keine Chance wir
haben die nicht gekriegt weil sie dann
so klein ist und dann doch auch so
wendig und wir haben die nicht vom
Himmel geholt bekommen aber die Drohne
wird dann genau über diesen
Schützengräben platziert und dann
schmeißen die das Ding runter und es
gibt unzählige Aufnahmen und das sieht
wirklich aus wie so ein ekelhaftes
Videospiel du siehst wie die unten durch
diese Gräben kriechen dann kommt diese
Granate diese
die Explosion einfach genau auf die
Leute drauf und dann zerfetzt ist diesen
Typen in diesem Graben und es bleibt
nichts mehr von dir übrig das ist so
brutal und der meinte die Fliegen in
drei vier 5000 Metern Höhe keine Chance
die zu kriegen kannst auch nicht
aufschießen kannst du alles vergessen
das einzige was hilft ist Flak der
deutsche Gepard der kann das und
deswegen ist der so gefragt in der
Ukraine weil du damit am ehesten Drohne
aber weiß ich überlegt dass du die
Drohnen an jeder Ecke überall einsetzen
kannst
da gibt's gar nicht ne den kannst ja nur
gezielt oder
genau und eben aber die so sowas wie
Patriot zum Beispiel kannst du dann dies
viel zu teuer ja natürlich könntest du
damit so ein Ding vom Himmel holen aber
es gibt so unendlich viele Drohnen so
viel Munition hast du gar nicht und
deswegen das ist eine ganz andere
Dimension und spielt offensichtlich in
diesem Krieg eine noch viel größere
Rolle als ich dachte auch wenn es darum
geht sozusagen Angst und Schrecken zu
verbreiten sag mal hat er in dein Gast
der ist dann wegen der vielen
Kriegsverletzungen zurück genau
ein Fazit daraus gezogen ja ich habe ihn
gefragt zum Schluss ob er das ob sich
das gelohnt hat und er sagte ja er wird
sofort noch mal machen also ist wirklich
davon überzeugt dass dort in der Ukraine
nicht nur die Freiheit der Ukraine
verteidigt wird
genau genau und ich habe ich habe und da
gibt's jetzt sozusagen die Verbindung
ein paar Tage davor ist schon mal
kennengelernt das ist ein Schriftsteller
russischer Schriftsteller eine toller
Schreiber der in Berlin lebt seit
relativ langer Zeit und der hinterher
als wir uns noch darüber ausgetauscht
haben fast geweint hat als er sagte
weißt du die Vorstellung dass ich nie
wieder mein Land sehen werde dass ich
nie wieder in meine Heimat zurückkehren
kann macht mich fix und fertig und das
habe ich so gut verstanden wenn man ich
kann mich da nicht blicken lassen bei
dem was ich schreibe der schreibt viel
über diese strukturelle russische Gewalt
und sagt es gibt eben zwei Spuren wenn
man dieser Gewalt die wirklich in dieser
russischen Gesellschaft eine riesige
Rolle spielt wenn man die verstehen will
sagt dann gibt es zwei Spuren die eine
für direkt rein in die Familien alle 40
bis 60 Minuten wird eine russische Frau
zu Tode geprügelt oder oder schlagen
erschossen was auch immer grauenvoll
alle 40 bis 60 Minuten stirbt in
Russland eine Frau und das ist noch
gewaltsame Todes und es ist auch nicht
mehr strafbar ich glaube seit 2017 hat
Putin das geändert also können sie nicht
ins Krankenhaus musste und ist häusliche
Gewalt eigentlich okay ist ist eins von
zwei europäischen Ländern wo das noch
sozusagen gesellschaftlich okay ist die
andere Spur führt in diese russischen
Gefängnisse jeder dritte russische Mann
war im Gefängnis oder ist im Gefängnis
und dort geht es auch um Gewalt es geht
um Erniedrigung es geht um die Frage
bist du opfer oder bist du kein Opfer
klar und Menschen werden systematisch
erniedrigt und was der erzählte das dass
diese diese sexuelle Entwürdigung Männer
ganz gezielt zu vergewaltigen ist Teil
dieser Entwürdigung und er sagt daraus
resultiert auch diese russische
Homophobie weil durch diese
Vergewaltigungen im im Gefängnis wird
Gewalt sozusagen im Kopf mit etwas
verbunden was maximal entwürdigend und
demütigend ist und deswegen auch diese
diese Homophobie ja also ähm
wir haben uns Syrien unter Gewinner der
in amerikanischen
hochsicherheitsgefängnissen saß und der
hat ja genau die gleichen Dinge
und du hast ja in den USA auch eine
nehmen wir mal kalifornia in New York
aus aber ansonsten ja auch eine
homophobe Gesellschaft und du hast ja
auch eine Gesellschaft mit einer großen
unterschwelligen Gewalt die haben
sicherlich nicht diese hohen
verprügelungszahlen aber eben
Waffenbesitz und ähnliche andere Dinge
Waffen Fetischismus
Rechtsradikalismus und so weiter warum
glaubst du ist in gerade in diesem
großen imperialen Ländern ja warum ist
das so stark
was interessante Frage ich hatte Dich
richtig drüber nachgedacht
interessieren
anders und da denkt man als erstes an
Dich oder Schweden ja das glaubt man
also werden mit Sicherheit sehr sehr
viel weniger Frauen verprügelt und
vergewaltigt und da gibt es sehr wenig
Waffen besitzt und dann geht's auch in
Gefängnissen wahrscheinlich ich meine
ich war da nicht aber deutlich anders
sollte ein russischen Gefängnis oder in
einem amerikanischen
hochsicherheitstraktik das dass manche
Länder so so gewalttätig sind und andere
so wenig also ich glaube prinzipiell zum
Beispiel also Deutschland wir haben ja
unsere eigene unvorstellbare Gewalt
Erfahrung gemacht
und ich glaube daraus haben wir was
gelernt das ist schon mein Gefühl aber
ich weil wir weil wir verloren haben
weil wir verloren haben aber wir wollen
hätten dann hätten wir ein riesen Kult
aus unserer Gewaltbereitschaft gemacht
vielleicht und das ist auch sagt auch
schonmalski also der zweite Weltkrieg
dieses gewinnen im Zweiten Weltkrieg
deswegen schon guter Punkt spielt in
Russland eine gigantische Rolle und
Putin hat das unglaublich wiederbelebt
es gibt Museen die dem Hooligan der der
der der große vaterländische Krieg der 9
mai ja der der dann der zelebriert wird
und so weiter er weiß erstmal ist das ja
verständlich ne wenn man sagt auf dem
Gebiet der der damaligen Sowjetunion
sind irgendwie während der Zeit des
Zweiten Weltkrieges 27 oder 28 Millionen
Menschen ums Leben gekommen was heißt
also mehr als jeder zweite kriegst tot
im Zweiten Weltkrieg war auf dem Gebiet
der ehemaligen Sowjetunion deswegen das
ist deswegen ja
Helden Denkmäler gibt das ist deswegen
Museen gibt dass das alles eine riesige
Rolle spielt das kann ich alles
verstehen die Frage ist ja mit was
verbindet sich das verbindet sich das
mit Nationalismus und Aggressivität ja
oder verbindet sich das was es ja auch
machen könnte mit mit gedenken mit
Pazifismus mit Einheiten mit dem
beschwören der Schrecken des Schrecken
des Krieges das könnte es ja alles auch
aber das Problem ist immer wenn man wenn
man gewinnt dann wird es immer eher die
erste Seite ja dann ist man stolz auf
sich ja egal wie gruselig das war wie
viel Menschen man verloren hat was
verstanden auf allen Seiten begangen
waren
gezwungen zum Nachdenken ist man ja nur
wenn man verliert
das ist der große Vorsprung der in
Deutschland hat ja das war aber es gibt
tatsächlich ich meine deswegen sagte ich
gerade blattlenste Thema
gesichtsprofessor war oder ist gibt
dieses Buch du hast das bestimmt gelesen
ja über diesen Streifen in Osteuropa
sozusagen vom Baltikum über Polen
Belarus bis runter zu kriegen
und das ist der Schauplatz im 20
Jahrhundert dieser unvorstellbaren
Gewalt Mal kam die deutschen mal die
Russen und beide brachten immer tot und
Elend in einem Ausmaß das haben wir hier
sozusagen in in diesem Land auf die Art
und Weise ja nie erlebt das richtig
obwohl wir den Zweiten Weltkrieg
verbrochen haben richtig ja genau stimmt
also sagen wir mal diese diese
zivilgesellschaftlichen Verheerungen ne
dass wir natürlich erlebt haben bei uns
ne den den weiteren Holocaust und die
Leute haben gesehen wie die Synagogen
abgebrannt wurden offener Straße
verprügelt oder umgebracht wurden also
das schon aber sie haben den den
Bürgerkrieg der deutschen untereinander
beeinflusst durch durch durch durch
durch Siegermächte oder das Siegermächte
kam ich meine gab's natürlich auch
Vergewaltigung und so nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg aber eben eine ganz andere
Nummer im direkten Vergleich zu dem was
in diesem Blatt passiert ist genau
natürlich
sagt eben dass das krasse ist er meinte
das fand ich so interessant haben wir
auch schon mal darüber gesprochen manche
weiß es ist nicht Putin der da reingeht
und Menschen weil leben die Köpfe
abschneidet das macht nicht Putin selbst
das machen ganz einfache Russen
und er sagt diese diese Gewalt ist
wirklich strukturell man muss das einmal
verstehen und ich habe das auch in in
Moldawien erlebt deswegen gibt es da
genau diese Aufmerksamkeit und auch
diese Angst auch im Baltikum bei den
Polen die wissen mit wem Sie es dazu tun
haben und und der sagt selbst wenn du in
Russland wenn du gegen Gewalt bist und
es gibt ganz viele nette sympathische
freundliche Russen möchte ich kenne auch
einige von denen und er kennt natürlich
ganz ganz viele da sagt das sind das
sind ganz nette Menschen aber wenn du
versuchst dich dieser Gewalt zu
entziehen du kannst es nicht diese
Gewalt kommt irgendwann auf dich zu oder
kommt hinter dir her du kannst dich dem
nicht den sehen weil die ganze
Gesellschaft mit Gewalt durchdrängt ist
und er sagt es entscheidend ist
natürlich immer der Kopf ganz oben und
dann gibt es Codes dann gibt es Sprachen
ja er sagt es gibt eben die böse zu sein
ist im russischen etwas Gutes ja böse zu
sein ist gut
nein aber das wird den Kindern schon in
der Schule so beigebracht ja sagt er ich
kann nur Boris schomatzki zitieren ja er
sagt doch es gibt es vielleicht auch
aber jetzt jetzt erzeugst du so ein
bisschen den Eindruck die russische
Gesellschaft wäre Mordor
also sozusagen als wenn er sozusagen den
Kult des Bösen zelebriert wurde da wäre
ich jetzt immer sehr sehr vorsichtig
kein Kult des Bösen aber aber
tatsächlich eine eine Bereitschaft zu
Gewalt die dann immer wieder
Grundschule sagt das schon wird das wird
das zelebriert und böse zu sein bedeutet
du bist dann nicht Opfer ja ja und und
und das Kot ist zum Beispiel sagt wenn
man jemanden wie Putin sagt wir wollen
jetzt Frieden schließen wir wollen es
doch vertragen lass uns irgendwo ein
paar Fähnchen hinstecken auf einer
Landkarte und dann sagen wir hier bis
hierhin jetzt euers und dann Umsatz das
bedeutet für denen okay sie sind schwach
und jetzt erst recht das ist die
Übersetzung von lass uns doch bitte
jetzt erstmal über Frieden sprechen das
versteht der vollkommen anders als wir
es verstehen das fand ich so interessant
und er sagt das ist in der Sprache aber
würden wir in der aus der militärischen
Logik heraus dass nicht genauso sehen
also du brauchst diese ganze Zelebration
des Bösen ja nicht um zu sagen wir als
erster ankommt und sagt wollen wir nicht
mal Frieden machen der hat Angst dass er
den Krieg verliert also dafür brauchst
du jetzt gar nicht das Böse sondern du
denkst sofort wenn also wenn die Stimmer
stelle sich mal vor ist können wir jetzt
ein großes Friedensangebot aus
russischer Seite nach dem Motto na ja
wir können aber alles reden auch dass
wir darüber aus wie wieder rausgehen und
so ich meine alles utopischer Quatsch ja
aber das würden wir auch sofort als
Signal der Schwäche interpretiert ja
aber die Frage ist dann was man daraus
folgt und er sagte ihm es gibt ihm im
russischen ein Wort bösesual und er sagt
bei uns ist es besser läuft also böse zu
sein weil das Böse ist auf Russisch oft
gut ein böser wach und ist ein guter
Wachhund und sagt unsere Lehrer haben
sogar von einer gesunden Bosheit zum
Beispiel beim Sport gesprochen
ja so und so eine gewisse ja so eine
gewisse Bosheit weil dann kann man am
Ende erfolgreich sein oder er nennt es
Gewalt russisch gesagt dieser Sprache
spricht Putin in den Perfektion
hat auch so andere kurz das fand ich so
interessant da sagte die maximale
Demütigung im Gefängnis ist Männer die
die Opfer sind die verprügelt werden die
vergewaltigt werden den wird dann häufig
der der Platz neben der Latrine so
zugewiesen ja der der soll sich aufs Klo
verziehen weil das ist der Ort an den er
hingehört und sagt erinnerst du dich als
Putin damals im Jahr 2000 ne
Tschetschenien Leute das vorhin erwähnt
hast hatte doch gesagt wir werden diese
Leute jagen und wir werden sie auch auf
dem Scheißhaus treffen
findest du dich daran nee das ist ein
ganz bekannter Satz von ihm und und das
war damals sozusagen die ultimative
Kriegserklärung für mich ich habe das
damals so gehört das war einfach wohl
eher Sprache aber er sagt im russischen
hat jeder hinten was er meint das war
der Code für da gehören diese Typen hin
das sind ne das sind diese Opfer und die
werden uns jetzt holen das bedeutet viel
mehr als einfach nur zu sagen da holen
wir jetzt Leute von der Toilette runter
das fand ich sehr interessant und das
versteht man nur wenn man mit jemandem
redet der der dort aufgewachsen ist und
der das genau versteht und hat mich
extrem beeindruckt dieses Gespräch
Richard deswegen und jetzt komme ich zum
dritten Punkt der mich in dieser Woche
irgendwie gepackt hat ja der Lars
klingwald zu Gast in der Sendung ja in
der gleichen Sendung nee das war eine
andere Sendung und Lars klingball
SPD-Chef der den Laden wie ich finde
sehr gut zusammenhält ich meine Werte
das gedacht dass wir mal hier sitzen und
über die SPD sagen es läuft gerade bei
denen keiner keiner erzählt mir diese
Geschichten über den anderen keine
Intrigen zumindest keine die man groß
mitkriegt sondern sondern erstaunlich
still ist richtig genau
und ich komme deswegen drauf weil ich
finde es gibt ja es gab ja jetzt gerade
das Jubiläum 160 Jahre SPD und dachte so
auch in diesem Gespräch mit thomaski wie
gut es ist dass es genau so eine Partei
wie die SPD gibt das ist diese Leute gab
Leute wie Otto Wels z.B die 1933 ja
gegen dieses Ermächtigungsgesetz von
Hitler gestimmt haben ja die sich
sozusagen gegen diese aufziehende Gewalt
ausgesprochen haben und der das
messerschar verkannt hat 33 was da auf
Deutschland zukommt und der damals
diesen berühmten Satz sagte Freiheit und
leben kann man uns nehmen die Ehre aber
nicht das ist sozusagen das der andere
Teil ja der eigentlich gut zu dem passt
was wir gerade besprochen haben es gibt
dem an der ist so entscheidend dass an
der richtigen Stelle Menschen aufstehen
und sagen pass auf wir sehen was ihr
davor habt und mit uns nicht wir machen
das nicht mit und ich finde die SPD hat
der große Verdienste also die Verdienste
der SPD sind völlig unbestritten sie ist
die mit riesen Abstand erfolgreichste
deutsche Partei
sie hat zwar nicht den erfolgreichsten
Bundeskanzler gestellt das war
wahrscheinlich Adenauer und cool aber
sie hat das
Fußball
sind einmal die lange Regierungszeiten
und zum anderen dass sie ihre Agenda in
einem beeindruckenden Maße umgesetzt
haben also bei Adenauer die
Westintegration der Bundesrepublik und
bei Kohl die Europäische Union
gigantische Projekte das zweite noch
größer als das erste das eben nur in
diesen langen Regierungszeiten und nur
mit Kanzler an möglich war die nicht nur
den Zug gezogen haben sondern den ganzen
Bahnhof deswegen waren sie sicherlich
die erfolgreichsten Kanzler aber wenn
man sich die Frage stellt wer hat die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland am meisten
geprägt wer hat sie zudem gemacht was
sie heute ist und spielt die SPD
sicherlich eine deutlich größere Rolle
als die CDU und wenn wir noch eher
anfangen und nicht nur sagen
Bundesrepublik sondern überhaupt
Deutschland ich meine dass der Wert
eines Arbeiters erkannt wurde dass man
erkannte dass es aus zwei Gründen sehr
gut ist Arbeitern höhere Löhne zu zahlen
als das was sie zum Überleben brauchen
einmal aus humanen Gründen und zweitens
das wirtschaftlichen Gründen weil dann
können Sie auch die Produkte kaufen die
sie herstellen
sehr große Rolle also so überzeugt man
die Fabrik wir sind da noch etwas hier
ja aber es ist aber wichtig ist
Freizeit um überhaupt einkaufen gehen zu
können ist nicht unwichtig
Einkaufen alle
modernisierungsbewegungen in die die
also von vom vom Kaiserreich ja von aus
der Welt Kaiser Wilhelms
am Ende über die Welt Adenauers zu zur
heutigen Welt geführt haben also wie
geht man heute in unserer Gesellschaft
mit Kindern um ja und wir haben nicht
das Böse als Erziehungsideale irgendwo
drin her wir sind das weitgehend
jedenfalls los
wie ist die Rolle der Frau in unserer
Gesellschaft ja wie gehen wir mit
Minderheiten in der Gesellschaft um dann
muss man sagen durch den ganzen Weg
hindurch ja die Modernisierung auch 68
zumindestens also nicht nur bekämpft zu
haben sondern auch die positiven Impulse
das ist egal ist ob jemand lange Haare
trägt oder kurze Haare trägt oder
Minirock oder andere Klamotten also
diese ganze Liberalisierung der
Gesellschaft ist ja immer von der SPD
vorangetrieben worden und meistens gegen
den Widerstand der CDU also man kann
schon sagen dass die SPD fast alles
erreicht hat was sie sich vorgenommen
hat
und ich würde sogar sagen alles erreicht
hat was sie sich wirklich vorgenommen
hat ja das Spiel nämlich in der SPD
immer eine große Rolle das was man sagt
dann dass man was man sich wirklich
vorgenommen hat waren in dieser Partei
nie ganz das Gleiche
und weil sie sich so zu Tode gesiegt hat
kam sie dann in diese schwierige
Situation als sie in kurzer Zeit ganz
viele Parteivorsitzende verschlissenheit
also Kurt Beck und Platzeck und bunte
Ferien und Andrea Nahles und so weiter
weil sie dann eigentlich nicht mehr
wusste wofür man sie noch braucht ist
richtig noch mal noch mal zu zurück
Richard zu dem Geist den das so atmen
wir haben gerade über Auto Wels
gesprochen diese berühmte Rede gegen das
Ermächtigungsgesetz das andere Ende
sozusagen von dem über das wir gerade
gesprochen haben ja dieses dieses böse
dass ich da plötzlich waren gebrochen
hat ich ich ich lese dir das mal kurz
vor was der damals in dieser Rede gegen
dieses Ermächtigungsgesetz gesagt hat
das war die Sitzung der Hitler dieses
Gesetz durchgesetzt hat also quasi das
Ende der Demokratie genau da wurden
Sozialdemokraten längst von Nazis
verfolgt bedroht verhaftet während
dieser Rede standen es a Männer im Saal
und welche stellt sich dahin und sagt
das trotzdem ja und sagt wir sind
wehrlos aber nicht eher los die Gegner
wollen uns an die Ehre daran ist kein
Zweifel aber dass dieser Versuch der
eher Abschneidung einmal auf die Urheber
selbst zurückfallen wird weil es nicht
unsere Ehre ist die bei dieser
welttragödie zugrunde geht das ist unser
Glaube bis zum letzten Atemzug Freiheit
und leben kann man uns nehmen die Ehre
aber nicht wenn du das liest 33 sagt er
das benutzt das Wort Welt Tragödie da
geht es einem doch kalt den Rücken
runter der hat klar gesehen
[Musik]
ja ja und dann Julius Leber der der auch
berühmter SPD Mann der 45 in Plötzen sie
hingerichtet worden ist
war einer der Beteiligten attent ne 20
Juli um um von Stauffenberg wird aber
schon am 5 juli von der Gestapo
verhaftet weil sie diese Verschwörung
irgendwie mitkriegen gibt es einen Schau
Prozess und der wird dann 45
hingerichtet und er sagt dann auch da
Gänsehaut für eine so gute und gerechte
Sache ist der Einsatz des eigenen Lebens
der angemessene Preis das Wahnsinn zwei
zwei beeindruckende Beispiele von
sozialdemokratischen Heldentum ja
wobei man auch sagen muss das ist
natürlich auch in dieser Zeit viele
Sozialdemokraten geben hat wie das
natürlich immer so ist die sich relativ
schnell angepasst haben und mit der
alten Sache nichts mehr zu tun haben
wollten aber ist natürlich sehr wichtig
auch für die Identität einer Partei das
ist uns wenn es sehr wenige gewesen sind
die aber so aufrecht
mit dem Wissen dass sie sich dabei
um ihr Leben bringen ihre Prinzipien
verteidigt haben ich finde das großartig
ehrlich gesagt also ich ich ich ich ich
denke oft über diese Zeit nach und frag
mich oft auf welcher Seite hätte ich
selbst gestanden ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich glaube das sollte gemacht
sollte keiner ja ohne diesen zu haben
von sich selber glauben dass er einhält
wäre richtig das darf man nur im
Nachhinein von sich sagen das darf man
sich in seinen Fantasie nicht mal
antizipieren das ist meisten Menschen
sind sehr viel schwächer als sie von
sich selbst glauben das war gibt Kurt
Schumacher auch so ein großer spd-name
klingt ja man kann die Geschichte der
SPD sehr schön eigentlich so und so ganz
berühmte setzen auch erzählen von
kurt-schumacher gibt es ein großartigen
Satz wenn wir irgendetwas beim
Nationalsozialismus anerkennen dann ist
es die Tatsache dass ihm zum ersten Mal
in der Politik die restlose
Mobilisierung menschlicher Dummheit
gelungen ist das ist schön auch der
erste Vorsitzender in der BRD kann der
berühmte Gegenspieler von von Adenauer
später genau ja von Anfang an der
berühmte Gegenspieler genau
in den meisten gar nicht mehr in
Erinnerung ist außer dass die
spd-parteizentrale ursprünglich nach ihm
benannt war in Bonn die die
Brandhaus ne genau ja also dass wir die
Brandhaus ist ja heute in Berlin und in
Bonn war es das erich-ollenhauerhaus
ansonsten werden sich nur dann nur Leute
über 70 noch irgendwie in ihre
eulenhauer erinnern du hast dich ja
Richard mit der SPD glaube ich auch sehr
intensiv auseinandergesetzt ne und
eigentlich beginnt das ja bei Ferdinand
Lassalle
ja der Vater der Sozialdemokratie
also ein ja also ich weiß nicht ob seine
sein Leben mal verfilmt ist er ist ja
glaube ich beim Duell ums Leben gekommen
also meine Frau ne ging
ein bisschen Playboy bisschen hassador
bisschen Abenteuer und so weiter also
eigentlich nichts was typisch für das
ist was wir uns heute wenn man gucken
wenn man denkt Sozialdemokratie dann
fällt einem ein Müntefering Wiener
Schumacher also solche Leute in Brand
sowieso ja
selbst Schmid würde mir nicht einfallen
was ich irgendwie nicht sicher bin ob
der wirklich in der SPD war aber
ansonsten das ist so das ist so das das
ist so so das was man damit verbindet
und eigentlich waren die Anfänger schon
etwas operettenhafter aber eigentlich
gibt es auch zwei Anfänger
weil das gibt einen zweiten Anfang um
wilhelm-liebknecht und August Bebel
herum so die hatten erstmal mit den
anderen gar nichts zu tun und die haben
sich wechselseitig auch als stärkste
Konkurrenz wahrgenommen und der Grund
ist der Bibel und Liebknecht waren die
Vertreter der Arbeiterschaft also das
proletariates was ist damals ja noch gab
ja wir reden über die 1860er Jahre ja da
war die wirtschaftliche Situation ein
ganz klein bisschen besser also 1830
oder 1840 als die Menschen noch wie die
Fliegen in den Fabriken starben aber man
kann sie sich kaum brutal genug
vorstellen Ausbeutung und so weiter
wie viele Stunden haben da Menschen
gearbeitet also in den schlimmsten
Zeiten 80 Stunden in der Woche und ich
80 und in der Zeit über die wir jetzt
reden also sicherlich häufig genug noch
über 60 Wahnsinn fast 7 Tage die Woche
ja und da waren sozusagen Vertreter der
Arbeiterschaft und das war Lasagne nicht
la salva der Vertreter der kleinen
Handwerkerschaft das ist eine andere
Gruppe
und deswegen war es so wichtig dass ich
diese beiden die jetzt die gleichen
Forderungen hatten mehr Lohn
Mitbestimmung freie Wahl Wahlrecht für
alle es gab ja kein allgemeines
Wahlrecht genau ja nur die Reichen
durften wählen und dass die sich obwohl
sie sich untereinander überhaupt nicht
leiden konnten
1875 auf dem berühmten Gothaer Parteitag
versammelt haben beschlossen haben und
da ist dann die die SPD wie wir sie
heute kennen gegründet worden aber diese
beiden Interessensgruppen ja die
durchziehen wie eine roter Faden die
Geschichte der SPD
denken ja genau Schröder ist dieser
seilseite ja und davon Lafont ist die
nebelseite und diese Auseinandersetzung
der könnte es denn jederzeit würdest du
lieber Schröder davon Handy in die
gleichen Gegenüberstellung finden
richtig linken Sozialdemokraten finden
oder inhaltliche Leute mal schreiben
oder wie Rudolf Dressler die das linke
oder er hat Äppler zum Beispiel es gab
also immer welche die so dieses dieses
wirklich Linke in der SPD vertreten
haben die aber nie mehrheitsfähig waren
heute so das linke ist immer weniger
geworden ja Mütze nicht wäre vielleicht
sozusagen noch derjenige ja der in
dieser Welt
hat auch mal ganz links angefangen ja
also das ist das gehört zu jedem
sozialdemokratten dazu dass er als JUSO
auffällt weil er so links ist und als
Kanzler auffällt weil er kein
Sozialdemokratie ist also das ist
eigentlich der der klassische Weg die
Evolution eines Sozialdemokratie
Scholz auch ne Scholz war ja auch mal
sehr sehr links unterwegs von der SPD ja
dabei den ich glaube ich auch mein
irgend so einer k-gruppe oder so was wie
ich meine ja auf jeden Fall ja genauso
wie wie Kretschmann der ja auch bei dem
Mao ist ein wahr oder oder Ulla Schmidt
die ehemalige Gesundheitsministerin die
also auch in der mauristischen Vollmer
und so Ulla Schmidt auch ja ja genau die
war glaube ich im KBW oder so
kommunistischer Boden Westdeutschlands
interessant der Fuchs ne der langjährige
Chef der Welt Stiftung von den Grünen
der war auch mau ist gewesen und auch
sehr interessant sehr heute heute ein
großer Befürworter von Waffenlieferungen
absolut also die was was Einzige was
gleich geblieben ist in den Ansichten
von Rudolf Fuchs ist die Rigorosität ja
und die Abqualifizierung derjenigen die
die Welt anders sehen ja ja ansonsten
hat er seine Meinung komplett immer
ausgetauscht aber was interessanter
finde ich
naja aber es ist das ist natürlich sowas
weil man sich nicht repräsentativ für
heutige Politiker wo man sagt ne
heutiger Politiker muss in aller erster
Linie irgendwie geschmeidig und
anpassungsfähig sein und immer auf die
die Wähler Mehrheit schielen und so
total da gehört ja natürlich gar nichts
zu aber weil du das gerade sagst Richard
lasal haben wir gerade darüber
gesprochen quasi der Vater der
Sozialdemokratie dann wirklich ironisch
bei diesem anachronistischen Ritual ja
wir schießen gegenseitig auf uns weil
wir bald um die gleiche Frau buhlen ums
Leben kommt was irgendwie nicht so
richtig passt aber es gibt einen total
guten Satz von dem und ich finde der
passt so und die Zeit alle große
politische Aktion besteht pass auf im
aussprechen dessen was ist und sie
beginnt damit und alle politische
Kleingeisterei besteht in dem
Verschweigen und bemänteln dessen was
ist und dann denkst du an das was wir
heute politisch häufig erleben
auf Umfragen gucken was kann man den
Leuten zumuten nämlich genau NICHTS ja
richtig und ja oder irgendwas ist müsste
bedeuten dass wir aufgrund der
ökologischen Katastrophe auf die wir
zutreiben und der Welt die wir unseren
Kindern und Enkelkindern vor die Füße
kippen viel viel zu wenig machen und
nicht wie man das aus der Presse glauben
könnte im Hinblick auf halbwegs
Bemühungen und so weiter zu viel ob wir
da immer das richtige machen dann lass
uns meine Sendung drüber machen da habe
ich eine Menge Kritik dran aber die
Tatsache dass wir so diesen Notstand
erkennen und wissen dass wir keine Zeit
mehr haben dafür kein Weg dran vorbei ja
und mich stört dann einfach wenn wenn
die Kritiker von Gesetzen die vielleicht
Schwachstellen haben oder Umwelt
Strategien und Nachhaltigkeitsstrategien
die vielleicht auch anders sein könnten
das alles eingeräumt der Kritik habe ich
auch aber dann nicht erkennen wie
unglaublich brutal ernst die Lage ist
ja sondern immer noch denken ist man
könnte jedes erdenkliche Privilegium
erhalten und so weiter also das ist das
was für mich unverständlich ist und zum
Thema sagen was ist ja wieso sind die
Sozialdemokraten da jetzt nicht dabei
die Grünen zu umarmen und zu sagen es
geht ab unser aller Zukunft genau das
habe ich warum Warum gefragt die zu ja
während sich da diejenigen dieses
versuchen sich eine blutige Nase holen
und halten sich so dezent im Hintergrund
damit sie von dem Ärger nichts abkriegen
ja man guckt zum Spielfeld dran zu und
wie sie sich wie sich alles auf habe
stürzt richtig und und es ist ja
interessant wie wir beklagen auch wir
beide also ich würde mich da nicht
ausnehmen ich beklage mich total häufig
über über Politiker die den Leuten
nichts zumuten aber wenn es dann
passiert
Gnade dem Gott ja dann geht's sofort los
und dann und damit wird das ganz große
fast aufgemacht das erlebt gerade Robert
habe echt hart was da passiert und ich
musste so an dich denken weil du hast
vor einiger Zeit in nach einem Gespräch
hier sagtest du wir haben so ein so eine
Mentalität der der Staat als
Dienstleister ja und wir so als Kunden
im Servicecenter die ankommen und sagen
jetzt bitte starte ich zahl dir Steuern
jetzt liefer mal bitte Bernd Ulrich von
der Zeit ja hatten ähnlichen Gedanken
dieser Tage geschrieben den ich super
finde irgendwie schreibt er ist in
Deutschland der Gedanke japanten
gekommen das Politik nicht nur darin
besteht denn Willen des Volkes in
Umfragen zu erahnen und dann gleich
einer Servicekraft umzusetzen das finde
ich sehr sehr schön das ist genau der
Punkt das ist absolut der Punkt ja aber
das ist natürlich die Art und das weiß
man als Politiker wie man am längsten
dran bleibt und am leichtesten hochkommt
ja das ist das Belohnungssystem das
Belohnungssystem ist nicht dass man am
Ende in 50 Jahren sagen wird gut was der
damals alles gemacht und versucht hat
sondern das Belohnungssystem ist in
unserem System die wieder war ja richtig
ja und das bedeutet halbwegs gut in den
Medien angesehen werden spielt dabei
schon mal eine ziemlich große Rolle und
ansonsten eben auch nichts zu machen
womit man irgendwo ernsthaft aneckt das
kann man ja in Friedenszeiten machen ich
meine mit Friedenszeiten jetzt nicht den
Krieg in der Ukraine ich meine ins in
Zeiten von Ruhe und Stabilität ja wo man
so wie Schröder sagte immer mit ruhiger
Hand regieren ne oder Merkels Raute ja
wobei man im Nachhinein sagen muss das
war völlig falsch ja Raute und ruhige
Hand denn die ökologische Katastrophe
zeichnete sich damals schon genauso gut
und mit jedem Jahr wo wir nichts tun
oder wenig tun wird das was in Zukunft
zu tun ist teurer teurer und teurer ja
und zwar teurer jeglicher Hinsicht
finanziell teurer fürs die Maßnahmen
anbelangt und moralisch teurer im
Hinblick auf das was man da
möglicherweise machen muss um das
Überleben zu sichern ja ich ich ich ich
bin da wieso man sagen
so gigantische Herausforderung ich habe
auch in dieser Woche ist war wirklich
die ihre Woche mit multiplativ darüber
gesprochen der sagte es stimmt nicht
also in Deutschland natürlich haben wir
viel gemacht wir haben den CO2-Ausstoß
um 40 Prozent gesenkt also da passiert
viel aber gleich
insgesamt
1990 aber in derselben Zeit ist er
global gesehen um 60% gestiegen das ist
ja sowieso ein Thema lass uns mal
darüber reden wieso wir eigentlich in
diesem ganzen nachhaltigkeitsthema was
die gesamte Menschheit anbelangt noch so
sehr in nationalen manchmal sogar
regionalen oder Bundesland spezifischen
Mustern denken ja also warum ist uns bis
heute nicht gelingt eine globale
Zusammenarbeit zu machen die davon
ausgeht wenn es darum geht alternative
Energie zu erzeugen wo ist in der Welt
der meiste Wind ja wo kann man das
meiste mit Wasserkraft machen wo scheint
am längste und am meisten die Sonne und
wohnt keiner ja also es muss ja
eigentlich viel stärker in diese
Dimension gehen und es ist entsetzlich
zu sehen wie wenig wir da vorankommen
und wie kleinteilig wir das machen und
uns immer darauf berufen zu sagen wir
müssen in Deutschland halt eine
Vorbildfunktion haben das ist doch
Quatsch wenn wir das hinkriegen sollten
was wir uns vorgenommen haben wird sich
Somalia daran kein Vorbild nehmen können
weil sie sich das gar nicht leisten
können den gleichen Weg doch niemals
gehen können das ist doch Unsinn wir
brauchen eine globale Umweltstrategie
aber gut darüber lasst uns eine eigene
Sendung machen
finde ich aber jetzt abschließen SPD das
also diese die 160 Jahre ich ich hatte
das Gefühl klingen weil es Lars klingen
weil es stolz sehr stolz darauf und
Parteivorsitzender genau dieser Partei
zu sein auf der Partei von Willy Brandt
und so weiter wird so sagen dass du die
die großen die entscheidenden Impulse
zum Schluss gefragt ähm tatsächlich sehr
sehr häufig mit der Sozialdemokratie in
Deutschland verbunden sind ja das würde
ich eindeutig sagen also ich denke dass
wir der
Sozialdemokratie die
mittelstandsgesellschaft verdammt ja
diese berühmte nivellierte
mittelstandsgesellschaft wieder
Soziologie das in den 60er Jahren
genannt hat also ähnlich wie die
skandinavischen Länder oder wie die
Niederlande eine Gesellschaft die
breiteste Bevölkerungsschicht wirklich
die Mittelschicht ist das ist etwas was
England zum Beispiel nie gelungen ist
und das Interessante ist muss man sich
fragen kann warum war die
Sozialdemokratie in Deutschland so
erfolgreich und die Labor Party in
England so wenig erfolgreich das ist
eine sehr spannende Frage und eines der
Geheimnisse liegt darin dass wir
zentrale
Gewerkschaftsorganisationen haben ein
DGB ja und dass die ganzen
Einzelgewerkschaften in Groß
Gewerkschaften wenige großgewerkschaften
unterteilt sind und nicht in lauter
Einzel- und kleingewerkschaften wie das
eben sehr sehr typisch die ganze Zeit
für England gewesen ist zum Beispiel
einer der Gründe gut gemacht hat und
dieser diese soziale
Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten die die
Sozialdemokratie erkämpft und eröffnet
hat gegen erbitterten Widerstand der CDU
ja also dass man sich gesagt hat auch
katholische Mädchen vom Lande so hieß
das damals ja sollten die Möglichkeit
haben Abitur zu machen
dass man Arbeiterkinder die Chance gibt
sozialen Aufstieg hinzukriegen dass man
wenn man diese Geschichte erzählt ist
ist eine wahnsinnig tolle weitgehend
sozial demokratische Erfolgsgeschichte
nicht nur aber weitgehend
sozialdemokratische Geschichte aber muss
dazu sagen diese Geschichte läuft seid
ihr 90er Jahren wieder rückwärts
ja das ist das Versäumnis der
Sozialdemokratie sie hat das Level auf
dass wir Mitte der 80er Jahre waren ja
in Europa führend was
bildungstransparenz anbelangt sie
Möglichkeit kam aus kleinen
Bildungsabschlüsse
ja ich war darauf immer neidisch aber
seit langer Zeit zurück ja und wir haben
seitdem auch Abfolgen
sozialdemokratischer Kanzler gehabt wir
haben die Schröder Zeit gehabt da ist es
eher schlimmer geworden und es wird auch
jetzt nicht besser das heißt also die
Sozialdemokratie kann sich ja nicht auf
ihren Erfolgen von gestern ausruhen
sondern sie muss sich fragen wo ist
eigentlich ihre sozialdemokratische
Agenda von ehemals geblieben
und und zum Schluss gefragt richard ist
Willy Brandt für dich der größte
sozialdemokratische Kanzler oder ist es
jemand anderer es ist Helmut Schmidt wo
bist du da will ich tue mich da schwer
ich tue mich da schwer ich glaube in
seiner in seiner historischen Bedeutung
die Brand damals hatte was die
Ausführung mit dem Osten anbelangt der
berühmte Kniefall gemacht
Video gemacht hat
dieser Satz wir wollen gute Nachbarn
sein wir wollen mehr Demokratie wagen
alles das was ich da mit dem Namen Brand
verbindet ist wenn man es zu in
historischen Dimensionen betrachtet weil
er sicher der wichtigste und
bedeutendste deutsche Bundeskanzler
so würde ich sogar sagen überhaupt ja
obwohl ich die Lebensleistungen von Kohl
und Adenauer vorher als erfolgreicher ja
als als größere längere Ära bezeichnet
hat wenn es um die Person geht Willy
Brandt und ich habe viele
Dokumentationen über über Brand gesehen
habe ich kein so positives Urteil wie
das allgemeine Image von handelt
von Brand ist sozusagen der das durch
und durch moralischen Menschen ja hier
stehe ich und kann ich anders und so
weiter und ich meine wenn man sich so so
das Leben von Brand anguckt auch er war
jetzt kein kein kein gradiger Moralist
also als ähm Regierender Bürgermeister
in Berlin das sehr viel mit den
Amerikanern auch mit den Geheimdiensten
zusammengearbeitet und so weiter und
hatte eine ganz andere Rolle als z.B die
Rolle dir dann als Bundeskanzler hatte
als er die Aussöhnung mit dem Osten
gemacht hat also auch er war sehr
chamäleonhaft er war ein begabter
Instinkt Politiker er war sehr chamä
traumhaft in seine Art dabei aber auch
sehr sehr gut daran sich den jeweiligen
Situationen immer wieder neu anfangen
aber das entspricht nicht dem Bild was
man verliert das Bild von Brand ist das
eines absoluten gesinnungstäters und das
glaube ich wird diese Person wie die
Brand nicht genau gerecht und deswegen
unterscheide ich die historische
Bedeutung und rein intellektuell war
Brand jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
beeindruckend rein intellektuell ist
Schmidt deutlich beeindruckend also wenn
man jetzt guckt so Analyse seine
geostrategischen Überlegungen dann auch
so diese diese Kunst jegliche Form von
Pathos als lächerlich und unnötig und so
darstellen sicherlich auch
ja ich finde ich finde ich finde auf
dieses ernüchternde das da drin steht ja
wenn alle angefangen und wollen ganz
hoch in die in die Luft hüpfen dann
erstmal so einmal in Ruhe eine durch
alle erstmal wieder unten sind und sagen
wir können auch gleich unten bleiben
also es ist ein gutes Gegengift ich
würde sagen man muss so sein Nikotin ein
gutes Gegengift ja warum nicht ja nein
aber ich finde ich finde so als
Gesamtkunstwerk finde ich Schmidt noch
ein bisschen beeindrucken dann ich weiß
nicht wie geht es Dir ich ich
Schmidt geht mir genauso
gerade in den letzten Jahren hatte
danach zum Teil echt merkwürdige Sachen
gesagt ja muss man sagen vielleicht hat
das auch was mit Nikotin Missbrauch zu
tun ich weiß es nicht aber es waren
wahnsinnig beeindruckender Typ und im
Grunde passte halt so gut in die Zeit ne
aber wir sind ja so eine hochmoralische
Zeit so und so so dieser Moralismus den
wir so wirklich wie so eine Monstranz
vor uns hertragen und da war halt mit so
unglaublich wohltuend anders ja und wer
sind wir dass wir ständig anderen zu
erklären haben wie sie gefälligst zu
sein haben ja und das das ist mir
persönlich erstmal sehr sympathisch weil
ich weil es nicht so anders ist aber
gleichzeitig finde ich wiederum also
Brand so dieser Instinkt zu sagen in
Warschau ich gehe da jetzt auf die Knie
als auch unter dem Eindruck dessen was
da passiert sich wirklich rein zu
stürzen diese Situation auch seine
persönliche Geschichte ja die Flucht
nach Norwegen und so weiter all diese
Dinge
Friedensnobelpreis und auch zu wissen
ich meine 1970 war dieser Kniefall im
Warschauer Ghetto das war nicht die Zeit
wo das alle ganz großartig fanden heute
gucken wieder drauf und sagen richtig ne
dass das wow kriegst du Gänsehaut wenn
du dieses Bild siehst dann muss keiner
was sagen aber damals waren fast 50% der
deutschen die Hälfte sagte auch woher
kommen ist ja gut jetzt aber bevor wir
nicht übertreiben so schlimm war das
doch alles nicht nein also das hier wenn
wir überlegt der Zeitgeist der 70er
Jahre ne ich war dann zu dem Zeitpunkt
als Brand Kanzler war so 89 10 Jahre alt
ich habe das mitgekriegt also in den
klassischen normalen CDU Haushalt der
etwas ganz anderes war als ich als CDU
Wähler heute
der Vaterlandsverräter ja und gut als
Kommunist beschimpft und und dadurch
dass wenn die die Gesellschaft
liberalisiert hat ja also gleichgesetzt
als pornograf und wegen seiner Frau und
Geschichten also irgendwie als als als
unsittliche Figur dargestellt und wenn
man sich überlegt was für Kampagnen das
damals waren also es gab dass der keine
Mord Anschläge über überstehen musste es
gab so einen Hass auf die Brandt wir
waren in der damaligen Zeit und er hat
diese Politik will dir nun wirklich
genau die Hälfte der Bevölkerung hinter
sich hat aber genau die Hälfte dagegen
und auch die Hälfte der Presse gegen
sich hatte
das trotzdem zu wagen und zu machen was
ist sich im Nachhinein als sehr weise
und sehr richtig und sehr Friedens
fördernd und so herausgestellt hat das
war beeindruckend und dann kann man sich
natürlich wirklich die Frage stellen bei
aller Kritik die ich vorhin am Brand
hatte welcher Politiker würde das heute
tun ja und da würde ich sagen sehe ich
jetzt im Augenblick keinen
sozialdemokratischen Kanzler den ich
auch nur entfernt so einschätzen würde
sondern da würde ich sagen das ist jetzt
gerade mal genau das Gegenteil von ihm
na das ist eben tatsächlich immer
Politik nach Kassenlage zu machen und
was mir am allerme ich am allermeisten
stört und das ist natürlich jetzt keine
Kritik an der Sozialdemokratie alleine
das ist der Verlust der langfristigen
Perspektive also die Politik über die
wir da geredet haben damals die Politik
branzt das war ja nicht eine Politik
nach Kassenlage oder für den Moment
sondern das war genau wie die
Westintegration Adenauers vorher mal die
Ausbildung mit den Osten einen auf
Langfristigkeit angelegtes Projekt die
tiefe Überzeugung dass das notwendig ist
die tiefe Überzeugung dass das notwendig
ist übrigens auch wieder aus zwei
Gründen es ging nicht nur um die
historische Versöhnung sondern es ging
damals auch schon um das russische Gas
und es ging damals auch schon über die
gewaltigen Absatzmärkte in der
Sowjetunion ja für die ganzen Leistungen
der deutschen Ingenieurkunst angefangen
mit Landwirtschaftsmaschinen und so
weiter denn in dem Gefolge der aus der
legation damals da waren Leute wie Otto
Wolf von amore und so weiter also hier
die rein so Schwerindustrie ja das das
hat er jetzt nicht gegen die deutsche
Wirtschaft gemacht sondern es gab sogar
ein starkes Verlangen wesentlicher Teil
der deutschen Wirtschaft ja auch hier
von Thyssen und Krupp und so weiter an
dieser Öffnung nach Osten klar also auf
neue Märkte da gehört beides zusammen da
kann man also Idealismus und
Pragmatismus gar nicht trennen okay und
deswegen auch deswegen also unter
wohlstandsgesichtspunkten weil diese
Politik damals richtig und wertvoll und
die frage mich heute mit welcher und du
beantwortest mir die Frage weil du
kennst ihn ja gut mit welcher
politischen Agenda ja auf
Langfristigkeit ausgerichtet ist Olaf
Scholz Bundeskanzler geworden
was ist ein großes Projekt was er in den
nächsten 12 13 Jahren seiner großen Ära
realisieren möchte also ich musste mir
entschieden widersprechen ich kenne ihn
gar nicht gut aber es gibt du hast den
hier im Podcast mal als moralische
Instanz bezeichnet ja im Sinne von ich
halte den für absolut integer Olaf
Scholz ist kein korrupter Mensch 0 0 und
das ist erstmal was Gutes wenn man das
über einen Kanzler wenn man das
sozusagen über den Kanzler dieses Landes
so sagen kann das kann man in anderen
Ländern so nicht sagen also stimmt hast
nur nach Amerika zu gucken guckst die
Donald Trump an und andere in Italien
ich bitte dich also das ist erstmal eine
riesige Qualität und dann gibt es und
das merke ich in letzter Zeit dann doch
mehr du du spürst hinter den Kulissen
sozusagen diese Idee
da gibt es auch um die Rivalität gegen
Robert habe ja also dem
Wirtschaftsministerium sozusagen da die
die die die Kompetenz wegzunehmen
sich wirklich aktiv um Wirtschaft zu
kümmern die merken dass da gerade was
auf die schiefe Bahn geraten ist es geht
jetzt wirklich um den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland das
heißt der deutsche Wohlstand ist in
Gefahr das haben die auch sehr klar
jetzt analysiert und für sich verstanden
das redet auch keiner mehr klein und es
gibt von von Olaf Scholz ich weiß nicht
ob die Geschichte stimmt aber es hat mir
mal jemand erzählt der sagte er hätte
Scholz als Bürgermeister hier in Hamburg
kennengelernt und Scholz hätte ihm die
rhetorische Frage gestellt was er denn
glaubte
dass die wichtigsten Aufgaben eines
Bürgermeisters in Hamburg sein die
wissen Sie die wichtigste Aufgabe im
Leben eines Hamburger Bürgermeisters ist
erstens Jobs zweitens Jobs und drittens
Jobs
und das ist der Punkt und ich glaube das
ist das was er vorhat und wenn er das
schafft ich glaube diese Aufgabe ist er
mir noch gar nicht richtig begriffen
wie groß wie groß würde ich was jetzt
auf uns zukommt im Zuge der Karriere
alles richtig gemacht aber ich habe
nicht gehört dass er das jetzt als
großes Regierungsprogramm ausgegeben hat
also mein Verdacht ist ja von den großen
Linien wo man von der Person Scholz
wegzukommen auch bei Merkel gab es das
ja nicht nee aber auch Merkel ist die
erste deutsche Kanzlerin genau die mit
einem
konservativen Programm angetreten ist
nämlich erhalten was wir haben ist ein
ganz großer Unterschied zu all dem was
vorher war
also Schröder ich hatte mich mit ihm mal
länger darüber unterhalten Schröder
wollte ein eigenständigeres Europa
gerade was militärisches und
Außenpolitik anbelangt das war seine
große Agenda das wird häufig vergessen
weil man mit ihm erster Linie die
harzreform
das was auch immer kommen will ne das
war die die Schröder Sache also raus aus
dem Windschatten der USA und eine Stärke
an europäischen Wirtschafts- und
außenpolitischen Interessen
orientierte Politik das war sein seine
große Agenda da ist er nicht dahin
gekommen wo er hin wollte und das ist
unter Merkel da wo die Ansätze dazu
waren tendenziell auch er wieder
rückgängig gemacht worden aber man kann
sagen er hatte zumindestens eine solche
Agenda und man könnte auch also wir
haben über über Adenauer gesprochen wir
haben über Brand gesprochen mit Kontext
eine solche Agenda nicht haben weil er
eine völlig krisengebeutelte
Kanzlerschaft hatte die reinfällt in
eine Welt
weite Rezession Merkel übrigens auch
aber gleichzeitig 15 Jahre positive
Wohlstandsentwicklung Konjunktur das ist
noch mal ein großer Unterschied also
sicher sehr viele Krisen aber im Fall
von von Schmidt ging es tatsächlich um
die Frage ob der bislang errungene
Wohlstand überhaupt zu halten sein würde
und ich glaube die Frage geht es wieder
Richard ich glaube die Frage geht aber
ich würde mir natürlich trotzdem ja
nostalgisch wie ich bin ja das ist
sozusagen das oder oder das Element das
Element lasall in mir also das verrückte
jemanden Wünschen mit einer
langfristigen Agenda für eine Welt in
der sich so viele Koordinaten verschoben
haben dass man einen sehr sehr guten
Kompass braucht um durch die nächsten
Jahrzehnte zu kommen und dann brauchen
wir mehr langfristig denken der Politik
in diesem Sinne vielen Dank ja hat Spaß
gemacht
bis dann tschüss
[Musik]
2 und Pots bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF